okay so
this is the pre-registration page where
you all have registered yourself for the
program metagenomics
and you will be able to find all the
details of the syllabus and also the
outcomes of each and every session the
topics and the outcomes and associated
resources as well on this page itself
and while you scroll uh down on the page
itself you will find four live sessions
that we have planned for the session
and these four live sessions will be on
overview of methods and applications for
metagenomics sequencing and analysis big
data analysis platform metagenomics
analysis on the t by info server so here
we'll be training and also get some good
hands-on practice with the pipelines on
the server and to mention the
participants of the metagenomics program
will be getting the educational license
where they can run their pipelines on
the server and analyze the data as well
the third live session will be on
interpretation and meaning that is
statistical analysis visualization and
interpretation using r and the fourth
one will be a very interesting one which
includes the future directions for full
metagenomic sequencing meta
transcriptomics and functional analysis
and we'll be having two guest speaker
sessions as well
where on january 8th that is actually
before the program begins dr gareth
trouble will be talking about unraveling
the hidden potential of active microbial
and viral communities
and the second guest
speaker session will be by dr
christopher m taylor and we have dr
chris here with us so uh
we welcome you dr chris and the session
will be on metagenomics and microbial
communities and this session will be on
21st of january at 3 pm cst
so here is the whole schedule of the
program and also now let's talk about
the registration
so to register yourself for the program
so here we received your preregistration
as your interest to invite you for the
free webinar so many of you get confused
with both of the registrations type now
to enroll yourself for the program you
need to visit the program page on the
learn.oxlogic portal and you will be
able to find the link here in the chat
box
okay so once you are here on the program
page again you will be able to first of
all see the whole session schedule along
with the dates the topics to be covered
and the associated resources and these
all resources are linked so this is for
the uh program participants that once
the session has been completed you will
be able to uh find i think the the
session dates are to be updated okay so
once the session has been completed you
will be able to look at the session
video under each of the sessions that is
after each session is completed the
recording of the same session will be
uploaded under the sessions tab
and also you can watch and go through
the recording and complete the resources
here on the program page itself
now to enroll yourself for the program
you need to scroll down where you will
get three levels the first one is the
beginner level the second is the
intermediate level and the third one is
the advanced level now what is the
difference between these three different
levels so in the beginner level you all
will be able to be a part of the
group sessions that we are going to
conduct and the intermediate level those
who require some extra training or have
some extra questions to ask or need more
precise help from the mentors then they
can go ahead with intermediate training
where they'll get one-on-one mentor
support and in the advanced license the
program participants will be able to
work on a research project and for that
research project they're going to get
some extra time period along with the
usual one and a half month time period
of the program so that is the difference
between these three different level
types now you can enroll or like pick
any of the subscription levels that
answers your requirements the best
and also when you scroll down you'll be
able to find a list of the program uh
coursework that that is associated with
this particular program
and the certificate
that you will be
getting on the completion of this
particular program
so that was the simplest way how you can
enroll yourself for this particular
metagenomics uh program now if you have
any queries please let me know in the
chat box so that we can
answer your questions
okay so if there are no more questions i
would like to put in we have a question
yes thank you sparsh so you can reach
out to us at
marketingthomasslogic.com for any of the
queries and we'll be able to help you
out with your questions and uh assist
you with your enrollment for the program
so the first session of the program is
on january 10th and uh you and though
the and the first session is a free
session everyone can be a part of the
session and go through the introductory
topics at first and get insights of what
all would be covered and how the program
would be working so that was all for
today's session i would like to thank
you all for being a part of the session
and if your questions were unanswered or
if you have any other question that
might
struck after this particular webinar
please feel free to mail us
uh yes definitely alex there are career
opportunities now all these training
programs that are that are being
conducted they are designed in this way
so as alia also mentioned we focus on
project based learning so yes there are
definitely uh career opportunities that
you will get uh
like you will be able to uh get yourself
a lot of for these opportunities after
completing these sorts of trainings that
omixlogic conducts
which will help you sharpen the topics
definitely and also help you uh give a
clear picture of how the concept of
methodologies could be applied to solve
a real life research problem and
do the analysis
yes
for that for your questions parsh will
be reaching out to you and she'll let
you know uh like what the research
fellowship program is and how it works
and how you can uh proceed from a
research fellow to an intern with
and please put your mail id in the chat
box so that sparse can reach out to you
or you can directly reach out to
marketing addresslogic.com
uh yes sofia us
we have few scholarships for the program
as well so we will be able to share with
you all the scholarship firm so just
after this particular webinar i'm going
to share the recording of the webinar
and along with the recording i'll also
share the scholarship forms that you all
that
the participants can fill out now in the
scholarship form you are required to
submit your curriculum video and after
reviewing your application we will let
you know what scholarship we can provide
you for this particular program now to
make sure that you receive the mails
from our end please make sure that you
add marketing addresslogic.com
to your mail address book because we
have been interacting with a lot of
users sometimes the mail gets into spam
or maybe promotional box so to get the
mails in your inbox don't forget to add
the marketing ad the marketing average
honest logic mail address to your